[Music]
thank you I'm talking about science and
spirituality and I'm interested in this
partly because I'm a scientist and
partly cuz I'm interested in spiritual
practices I've written two books
recently about science and spiritual
practices the first is called science
and spiritual practices the second one
perhaps more enigmatic li is called ways
to go beyond and why they work and you
know there's really a part of the same
project each book discusses seven
different spiritual practices which have
now been studied scientifically and I
think this is the most exciting way in
which science and spirituality are
coming together at present because if
you just have a purely theoretical
argument you'll have people who'll say
spirituality is all complete nonsense
it's rubbish it's superstition
on the grounds it's unscientific and
then there are people who did spiritual
things religious people and so on but
things are much more interesting now
than they used to be because we now have
access to spiritual practices from the
entire world's traditions and when I was
growing up I've never heard of yoga or
meditation and now there are millions of
people doing yoga and meditation all
over the world far beyond their home in
India we have access to all these
different spiritual traditions and
there's also a tremendous upsurge in
interest in spirituality at the moment
although organized religion is declining
in Europe and to some extent in North
America the the interest in spirituality
is accelerating and it's a remarkable
phenomenon of the modern secular world
partly because there's so much interest
in the secular context there's now been
a lot of scientific research literally
thousands of papers who in peer-reviewed
journals have studied the effects of
religious and spiritual practices on
people's health and well-being
the results are unambiguous taking part
in religious and spiritual practices
generally speaking makes you happier
healthier and live longer the converse
presumably is also true not taking part
in them makes you unhappy err unhealthy
and live shorter which is why I think
militant atheism should come with a
health warning because it often detaches
people from their traditional religious
practices and leaves them nothing in
their place now many atheists have now
recognized exactly this fact and the new
generation of atheist people like Sam
Harris are now into spiritual practices
Sam Harris who's one of the so called
new atheists is now giving online
meditation courses Alain de Botton who's
one of our leading atheist philosophers
in Britain read a book called religion
for atheists and he trying to recover
the benefits of religion for people
who've left their ancestral religion or
that of their parents or grandparents
because he thinks it's so important for
people's health and well-being so this
is the situation we're in and I'm going
to talk I don't have time to talk about
all 14 practices I described in my books
but I'll start with just one of them
which a gratitude which is the simplest
to investigate scientifically positive
psychologists are a School of Psychology
that's been going on since about 2000 as
a kind of official part of academic
psychology and it's about what makes
people happy as opposed to more
traditional forms of psychology which
are about what makes people miserable
and so positive psychology has looked at
what kinds of situations are people most
happy in and one of the answers is that
when they're in the state of flow if
they're it can be dancing singing being
absorbed in work having a great
conversation being in a state of flow is
very conducive to happiness and many
spiritual practices
DUS states of flow one of the things
that positive psychologists did by
looking at people who are happy is to
find out what kind of characteristics
happy people had and they found that
happy people are very often grateful
people and the critics then said well of
course they're grateful they're grateful
because they're happy so so they tried
to find out whether they were happy
because they were grateful and they did
some simple experiments one of them
involves taking a group of people like
this who divided into three groups at
random one group is asked to write a
list of hassles and problems they've had
in the previous week the other group
just writes a story about something that
happened and the third group writes a
list of things for which they feel
grateful good things that have happened
things for which they feel grateful and
the people who simply make a list of
things they feel grateful for
immeasurably happier four days
afterwards the exercise that was most
that had the biggest effect in their
experiments was what they called the
gratitude letter they they asked people
to think of someone who'd helped them in
their life who they'd never properly
thanked or acknowledged it could be a
family member a teacher a friend and
write them a letter thanking them I they
then went to that person read them the
gratitude letter people who did that
were happier for two months afterwards
as a result of this simple exercise now
all religions encourage gratitude there
are lots of hymns of praise and thanks
in the Christian hymn books in all
religions have ways of expressing
gratitude and a very traditional way of
doing it
in many families throughout Europe and
in other parts of the world is by giving
thanks before meals saying grace before
meals in a secular society that's
exactly the kind of practice that drifts
away people just give it up or forget
about it or pay no attention so now in
most households in Britain before meals
in at least in those households where
people still sit down together to eat
there's often an awkward pause before
the meal and someone says oh oh do start
it will get cold
like that a kind of gap where the grace
ought to be in traditional institutions
like Cambridge colleges there is a long
Latin grace my own college Clare College
has a long grace before dinner every
evening and although most people
probably don't pay much attention or
understand the Latin at least it
provides a kind of pause before eating
and in my books I suggest simple
exercises anyone can do and one very
simple exercise of gratitude is to pause
before a meal at home what we do is hold
hands so we have a short period when we
link together in a circle around the
table and people can give thanks in
there and where you or someone says a
grace usually me or we sing a grace it
makes a big difference to have that
beginning to a meal and if it's done
silently by holding hands even if some
people they're atheists or even militant
atheists holding hands it isn't
challenging anyone's belief system it's
simply providing a space for gratitude
keeping note so a gratitude journal is
another very good way of made daily or
weekly accounts of things you're
grateful for counting your blessings
very old-fashioned thing to do but very
effective it's so effective that in
America where things any new opportunity
for making profit is seized on
immediately you can now buy expensive
beautifully produced gratitude journals
from gift shops to write your lists of
gratitude of things you're grateful in
you don't need to buy a gratitude
journal you can do it on scrap paper on
your telephone or on your computer or
just make a mental note anyway gratitude
is a practice that anyone can adopt very
easily and it makes a big difference
what you're grateful for depends on your
belief system and this is where the
difference between believers
non-believers people are religious
people are spiritual but not religious
everyone can agree about the importance
of gratitude but then your belief system
affects how far you go everyone can
agree we're grateful to the people who
cook the food who make it who prepare it
the farmers who grow it the people who
distribute
it bring it to our tables we can be
grateful to the whole earth for the soil
the plants the sunlight that enables
these plants to grow so far that's
uncontroversial but then you could go
further and say you feel grateful the
very source of all life itself the
source of consciousness the the very
fact we're alive and in fact there's no
limit to how far you can go until you
come to the ultimate source of
everything you may want to stop short
and of course there isn't time for all
this before the average meal but the
belief system comes in not in ruling out
gratitude or endorsing but in how far
you go in your gratitude now in
meditation we reach a similar situation
where lots of people meditate about 18
million Americans now meditate millions
of people in Britain meditate how many
people here do or have meditated well
that's most people so the research on
meditation shows that people who
meditate have physiological benefits
lower blood pressure all sorts of
physiological benefits to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit a I dot TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas